talked about
um the visual style but what about like
the crafting and the narrative that's
all that's I want to know like how you
feel about the story because narrative
is a very safe narrative like you you're
not gonna expect anything more really
that like look I don't think anyone play
zombie apocalypse game or watch a zombie
apocalypse move for The Nair lisbee Road
it's it's always very simplistic we are
stuck in a town There's zombies
everywhere and we're trying to survive I
literally just told you the beginning
middle and end of this game pretty much
yeah but we're here for the experience
but they they do do a lot of nice
mechanics in the game that make the
gameplay change different that there
there is exploration like there's this
mission where they're like yo go go into
this place and then that leaves you
going to a hotel and you're like 24's up
and there's fire everywhere and you have
to like go back and forth between the uh
between the elevator shafts and it's
just like little little things like that